you've done a lot of work on fear that
was one of the things that you mentioned
before is there something that everybody
is scared of because i've heard
the
story the wives tale babies are born
with is it fears of heights and loud
noises or something is there any truth
in that or is there something everyone's
scared of there is i think the one that
everybody who has a healthy nervous
system will react quite robustly to is
if you start increasing the amount of
carbon dioxide
that they're breathing and reduce the
amount of oxygen that they're taking in
that's terrifying am i right in thinking
there's a
experiment you can do where it's a
single breath
and that is pretty reliable at bringing
on a an anxiety attack yeah if you have
people please don't do this because you
need the right proper medical staff
around but they're they're great
experiments of having people breathe
carbon dioxide directly and it
you basically panic
um it's terrifying yeah one big gulp of
carbon dioxide will make make you very
afraid it turns out that there are a
little group of neurons of course
neurons are just nerve cells that little
group of neurons in the brain stem that
respond to levels of carbon dioxide in
the blood turns out the reason we
breathe is of course to bring in oxygen
and then off low carbon dioxide
but
we don't have neurons that stimulate
breathing for oxygen we have neurons
that sense when carbon dioxide levels
get too high so if you hold your breath
eventually carbon dioxide levels go up
and then at the moment that they reach a
certain threshold these neurons fire and
trigger the gasp reflex
so in that moment you bring in oxygen
and then of course you offload some
carbon dioxide that's why it's so
important to work on co2 tolerance right
for breath work yeah so
free divers
a sport i actually don't recommend
because there's only one way out of that
sport as they say
i have some friends who are free drivers
and obviously you can do it safely with
the right guide and training etc but it
is a very dangerous sport because for
most people when carbon dioxide levels
increase in the bloodstream and brain
triggers this gas reflex what
free divers train is carbon dioxide
tolerance so they do that a couple of
different ways and again please don't do
this because you actually people have
died doing this which so one way is you
can do what's called cyclic
hyperventilation
right you do that 25 times or so and you
think oh you're bringing a lot of oxygen
you are but you're also offloading a lot
of carbon dioxide especially if you use
forceful exhales normally humans breathe
through active inhales
and passive exhales you just they just
sort of dump their air passively
but if you do cyclic hyperventilation
you're dumping a lot of carbon dioxide
and then if you were to
hold your breath what you would find is
you could hold your breath for a lot
longer why because your carbon dioxide
levels are reduced so you don't have the
same impulse to breathe now on land
that's a more or less safe thing to do
provided that you can get a good gulp of
air once the gas reflex hits
if you do that before going underwater
cyclic hyperventilation they call it air
packing and then you go under water
you're going to be able to
excuse me cyclic hyperventilation to air
pack and then
go underwater
but your
carbon dioxide is then lower you're
going to be able to stay under longer
but this is very dangerous because
normally when that carbon dioxide
threshold hits
you would
pop up to the surface you sort of panic
and want to go to the top free divers
learn to tolerate
high levels of carbon dioxide in their
bloodstream and stay very very calm the
way they die is very interesting
because it speaks to the physiology the
way they they die is they'll just be
swimming
feeling completely calm because they're
very used to they've trained up this co2
tolerance carbon dioxide tolerance and
when they die they don't suddenly feel
like oh my goodness i'm running out of
air it's just lights go black that's it
they're just black out and so they're
alive and then they're gone
and so this is why they use spotters
they you know they have a line et cetera
anytime you hear about somebody
dying doing free diving it's rarely
because they weren't
comfortable at a given depth or because
it's not because of that their gasp
reflex has kicked in it's because their
gas reflex has been so desensitized that
it's after the point at which they die
precisely and this you know it's sort of
like when you hear that um
skilled parachuters die why well because
they're so comfortable with so many
jumps they actually forget to pull
there's sometimes there are many
instances in which they're they're uh
videoing
the first time jumpers right and they're
getting the video for them and they
themselves forget to pull because
they're so comfortable jumping out of
planes and so as people get more and
more advanced in something there's a
there's a new risk that that surfaces
because
unless it's very reflexive and they
built all all the protocols in
oftentimes they can overlook the very
thing that allowed them to become expert
in the first place what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace